Ein Vakuum in der Physik bedeutet nicht gleich
absolute Leere.
Im Gegenteil: Forschungsteams weltweit sind
sich laut der Quantenfeldtheorie einig, dass
solch ein leerer Raum in Wahrheit voller Energie
steckt.
Wie großartig wäre es, diese anzuzapfen
und als schier unerschöpfliche Energiequelle
zu nutzen!
Würde somit nicht sogar ein Perpetuum Mobile
möglich, das einen Energiegewinn aus dem
Nichts meint?
Die unzähligen Theorien dazu sind super spannend
- und die interessantesten Facts bekommt ihr
jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science
Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los gehts!
Und an dieser Stelle auch noch einmal vielen
Dank für diesen coolen Themenvorschlag von
Euch über Whats App!
Herzlich willkommen!
Hört sich erst einmal an wie ein Widerspruch,
ist aber keiner.
Denn fest steht: Das Quantenvakuum ist alles
andere als leer.
Ihr könnt es Euch quasi vorstellen wie einen
brodelnden See aus Teilchen und Antiteilchen,
die entstehen und vergehen.
Quantenmechanische Gesetze beschreiben Partikel,
die innerhalb weniger Sekundenbruchteile in
die Existenz blitzen und dann sofort wieder
verschwinden.
Mit Teilchen und Antiteilchen sind beispielsweise
Elektronen und Positronen gemeint, die zugleich
entstehen, aber sich auch sofort gegenseitig
wieder zerstrahlen.
Dadurch entstehen elektromagnetische Felder,
deren Spuren man im Universum finden kann.
Das alles lässt sich wunderbar mit der Heisenbergschen
Unschärferelation erklären.
Demnach wandelt sich die Energie, die man
dem Vakuum für kurze Zeit entzieht, in die
virtuellen Teilchenpaare um.
Derselbe Prozess läuft auch beim absoluten
Nullpunkt, also bei 273,15 Grad Celsius ab
- daher auch die offizielle Bezeichnung der
“Nullpunktenergie”.
Schon ungewöhnlich, schließlich kommen bei
hier alle energetischen Prozesse zum Stillstand
- zumindest bei normaler Materie.
Und nein, das alles sind nicht nur theoretische
Konzepte.
Denn schon vor mehr als 70 Jahren gelang es
dem Physiker und Nobelpreisträger Willis
Eugene Lambs die Quantenfluktuationen in einem
Vakuum in einem Experiment zu nachzuweisen.
Vielleicht habt ihr selbst ja sogar schon
mal was von der sogenannten Lamb-Verschiebung
gehört?
Hierbei verschieben sich bestimmte Energieniveaus
in der Elektronenhülle von Wasserstoff.
Verursacht wird dieser Effekt durch Wechselwirkungen
des Hüllelektrons mit den Feldern des Quantenvakuums.
Die Vakuumenergie selbst wurde 1958 in einem
Experiment belegt.
Danach wurde dann der sogenannte Casimir-Effekt
benannt, der eine Kraft beschreibt, die auf
zwei sehr eng beieinander liegende, parallele
Metallplatten wirkt und diese durch das Quantenvakuum
zusammendrückt.
Denn zwischen den Platten können sich keine
Teilchen befinden, deren Wellenlänge größer
ist als der Abstand der beiden Platten selbst
- außerhalb der Platten dagegen schon.
Hier entstehen viel mehr davon als zwischen
den Platten und erzeugen so im Großen und
Ganzen einen Druck, der die Platten von außen
nach innen zusammenschiebt.
Manche sind ganz vereinnahmt von der Existenz
der “freien Energie”, wie sie es nennen.
Die große Frage hierbei: Wie genau könnten
wir das Vakuum als unerschöpfliche Energiequelle
anzapfen und nutzen?
Doch ich muss Euch gleich enttäuschen, denn
diese Idee ist nicht umzusetzen.Denn fest
steht: Das Vakuum ist der Zustand der niedrigsten
Energie - so kann man ihm also KEINE Energie
entziehen.
So dient “Vakuumenergie” eben nicht als
Energiequelle.
Theoretisch gesehen GÄBE es aber einige Möglichkeiten:
Dazu müssten die paarweise auftretenden Teilchen
getrennt werden - und das ohne Energie aufzuwenden.
Dann könnten sie weiter einzeln genutzt werden.
Doch wie soll das in der Praxis funktionieren?
Auf diese Frage konnte bisher noch niemand
eine Antwort finden.
Eine weitere Einschränkung gibt es außerdem:
Die Energiedichte des Vakuums ist nicht sehr
groß, sodass sehr sehr viele Teilchen getrennt
und eingefangen werden müssten.
Wenn man sich den Casimir-Effekt genau anschaut,
könnte man auf die Idee kommen, die Bewegung
der Platten zu nutzen, die ja durch das Quantenvakuum
zusammengeschoben werden.
Beispielsweise könnte man so mit einem Hebelgestänge
Energie ziehen.
Doch dann ist auch klar: Dieselbe Menge an
Energie muss wieder in das System investiert
werden, um die Platten wieder zu trennen.
Doch sowohl Esoteriker- als auch Forschungsteams
weltweit haben die Hoffnung noch nicht ganz
aufgegeben.
Beispielsweise hat der US-Physiker Robert
Forward eine “Quantenfluktuations- Batterie”
entwickelt - zumindest im Gedankenexperiment.
Hier werden elektrisch leitfähige Platten
gestapelt, die alle mit der gleichen elektrischen
Ladung geladen sind.
So stoßen sie sich ab - entgegengesetzt zur
Casimir-Kraftt, die die Platten zusammenschieben
will.
In dem Gedankenexperiment müsste die Abstoßungskraft
so eingestellt werden, dass sie etwas schwächer
ist als die Kraft des Quantenvakuums.
Denn dann würde sich die Energie des elektrischen
Feldes zwischen den Platten erhöhen und die
Nullpunktsenergie würde in elektrische Energie
umgewandelt.
Einen ähnlichen Gedanken verfolgt auch ein
Forschungsteam aus Cambridge.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
wollen durch die Balance zwischen der elektrostatischen
Abstoßung und der Casimir-Anziehung kleine
Sensoren und Schalter basteln.
Und jetzt noch ein kleiner Funfact für Euch
am Ende: 2014 hat ein internationales Forschungsteam
eine Studie veröffentlicht, nach der die
mysteriöse Dunkle Energie durch das - ihr
ahnt es schon - Quantenvakuum entstehen könnte.
Wir haben hier schon öfter darüber berichtet:
Fast drei Viertel des Kosmos sind Schätzungen
zufolge mit dieser exotischen Form der Energie
erfüllt.
Sie sorgt wohl dafür, dass sich das Universum
ausdehnt.
Vielleicht hat auch in dieser Sache das “Nichts”
eine außerordentlich große Wirkung!?
Wenn es Neues zu diesem Thema gibt, dann erfahrt
ihr es natürlich hier.
Heute gibt es bei uns übrigens den 10 Jahre
Jubiläums, 500tausend Abonennten-Spezailstream
zu DEM Thema der letzten Wochen Aliens.
Hier könnt’ ihr ihn schonmal vormerken.
Um 18 Uhr geht es los und danach geht es für
Mitglieder un Patreons noch weiter.
Stellt uns gerne jetzt schon eure Fragen zum
diesem Thema, die wir dann im Stream beantworten
können!
Gerne auf WhatsApp, der Link ist hier.
Ich freue mich auf viele Fragen und natürlich
euch im Livestream.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!